Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Buon pomeriggio.
Oggi vi voglio parlare di un sogno:
il sogno della cura dei sani.
Naturalmente, quando dico cura
non intendo terapia,
anzi è proprio il contrario.
Ma lo intendo nel senso di Battiato:
io mi prendo cura di,
ho cura di te, mi interessa qualcosa.
"I care", diremmo in inglese.
Ma in effetti, se ci pensiamo,
quando parliamo di questo argomento
l'organo istituzionale
che si occupa dell'argomento
si chiama "Ministero della Salute".
E non si chiama
"Ministero delle Malattie".
Ma malgrado ciò anche noi,
quando pensiamo alla nostra salute
ci immaginiamo subito
la farmacia, l'ospedale,
la sala chirurgica, l'ambulatorio.
E pensiamo alle malattie.
E pensiamo che le malattie
siano tutte diverse:
le malattie cardiovascolari, i tumori,
le malattie neurodegenerative.
Siamo nella situazione in cui era Tolomeo
quando ha pensato che la Terra
fosse al centro dell'Universo,
e che tutto girasse attorno alla Terra.
Poi è venuto Copernico,
e ha convinto tutti che non era così,
ma che era il Sole al centro.
E quindi ha cambiato,
ha fatto quella che chiamiamo
una "Rivoluzione Copernicana".
Allora, oggi ci troviamo nella medicina
con l'esigenza, col desiderio,
di fare una rivoluzione copernicana.
Al posto della malattia,
vogliamo mettere al centro della medicina
la persona, l'uomo.
Ma quando pensiamo all'uomo,
abbiamo una tradizione tale
che pensiamo immediatamente
all'uomo sofferente, all'uomo malato.
Come questo incappucciato
della processione del Giovedì Santo
che si svolge a Lanciano, in Abruzzo.
E noi ci immaginiamo
che da questo modello dell'uomo malato
possiamo ricavare delle informazioni utili
per tutta una serie di altre persone
che, come vediamo, sembrano tutte uguali,
per cui il modello del malato va bene.
In realtà, se cogliamo gli incappucciati
in un momento in cui
non hanno il cappuccio,
ci rendiamo conto che sono
l'uno diverso dall'altro,
e che quindi questo modello non va bene.
Voglio quindi utilizzare qui
una frase famosa, di Don Milani,
che diceva "L'obbedienza
non è più una virtù".
Io voglio dire: in medicina,
l'uguaglianza non è più una virtù.
Non siamo tutti diabetici,
non siamo tutti ipertesi,
vogliamo vedere le cose
in un modo diverso.
Certo, se fossimo come questi ombrelloni
di Rimini, tutti uguali,
sarebbe una cosa molto più semplice:
ma in realtà, la nostra situazione
è più vicina a quello che voi
vedete adesso, in questa immagine.
Ma davanti a questa confusione,
davanti a questa complessità
della situazione degli uomini,
che cosa possiamo fare?
Una quindicina di anni fa,
con il mio gruppo di ricerca,
che operava in Molise,
abbiamo pensato di cambiare
un po' la prospettiva.
E di fare uno studio
che dal nome stesso,
dal titolo stesso del progetto,
"Moli-sani",
sottolinea e indica chiaramente
che siamo interessati di più
alla salute che alla malattia.
E siamo interessati di più
a capire cosa c'è prima,
cosa c'è all'origine
del benessere dell'uomo.
Abbiamo sorteggiato,
come diceva Brett stamattina,
abbiamo sorteggiato 30 Paesi, in Molise,
e siamo andati a chiedere al Sindaco
la lista dei residenti.
E in ogni paese abbiamo preso
un numero di persone,
abbiamo sorteggiato un numero di persone
proporzionale al numero degli abitanti;
e alla fine abbiamo preso 25.000 persone.
Era una cifra veramente
che all'inizio mi ha impressionato.
E abbiamo pensato: adesso vediamo
com'è, questa popolazione.
E però subito ci siamo resi conto
che non valeva la pena
di sapere quanti tumori c'erano,
quante malattie cardiovascolari.
Abbiamo pensato di andare
un pochino più alle radici.
E ci siamo immaginati che le malattie
che a noi sembrano così diverse,
in realtà, se andiamo a scavare sotto,
vediamo che sono come degli alberi,
che hanno delle radici o comuni
o comunque che si intersecano molto.
Allora il nostro interesse si è spostato
dalle foglie e dai rami sulle radici.
Vi faccio qualche esempio
di che cosa abbiamo trovato
in questa indagine.
Una delle radici che è alla base
di quegli alberi che abbiamo visto
è l'infiammazione.
Noi sappiamo - l'infiammazione,
ci immaginiamo una febbre altissima,
un dolore alle ginocchia
che non ci fa camminare,
le artriti, le artrosi
e tutto quello che vi potete immaginare.
Ma questo è già qualcosa che è successo.
Noi non vogliamo fare
una medicina di "Guardie e Ladri".
[In Guardie e Ladri], prima aspettiamo
che i ladri facciano un'operazione;
e poi le guardie li inseguono.
E noi facciamo uguale: aspettiamo prima
che si sviluppi una malattia,
prima che si sviluppi
e si manifesti un'infiammazione;
e poi gli andiamo dietro,
cerchiamo di curarla.
Non è così.
Vogliamo vedere piuttosto qualche cosa
che rassomiglia meglio a questa immagine.
Non ci interessa
la parte dell'iceberg che si vede:
sì, lo vedono tutti,
questo lo può vedere
la medicina tradizionale.
Noi vogliamo andare più sotto,
vogliamo andare a studiare, a capire
cosa c'è nella parte
nascosta dell'iceberg.
E questo, vi assicuro,
è un'impresa molto affascinante.
Qualche esempio: questa infiammazione -
che non è appunto il dolore, la febbre -
può essere misurata in un modo
che abbiamo elaborato
nei nostri laboratori
e che chiamiamo infiammazione subclinica.
Tutti noi, qui, abbiamo
un'infiammazione subclinica;
ma nessuno di noi lo sa, neanche io.
Ma se andiamo a misurare,
in una popolazione come i molisani,
questi parametri,
ci accorgiamo che c'è una diversità.
Nessuno se ne rende conto,
però abbiamo potuto vedere
che man mano che aumenta
questa infiammazione subclinica,
aumenta nientemeno
che il rischio di morire.
Quindi noi camminiamo tranquilli,
portando dentro di noi
un'infiammazione subclininca
che determina, favorisce
quello che sarà
il nostro rischio di morire.
È una cosa veramente affascinante.
Allora, uno subito dice: dammi il farmaco,
voglio ridurre questa infiammazione.
Eh no: il farmaco viene dopo.
Fa parte di quella medicina
che noi non vogliamo fare.
Che cosa possiamo fare per ridurre,
nella nostra vita di persone sane,
questa infiammazione?
Allora abbiamo potuto studiare, e capire,
che mangiare in modo Mediterraneo -
dalle nostre parti
è abbastanza frequente -
aderire alla dieta mediterranea
riduce questa infiammazione,
di cui nessuno si accorge;
ma neanche noi, mangiando
la dieta mediterranea -
frutta, verdura, olio d'oliva,
un pochino di pesce e così via -
nessuno si accorge che, mangiando,
si riduce l'infiammazione.
Sono tutte cose che vanno sotto l'iceberg:
ma determinano in maniera importante
quello che è adesso la nostra salute
e quello che potrà essere, un domani,
il rischio di ammalarci
o addirittura di morire.
Allora abbiamo voluto verificare:
se la dieta mediterranea
riduce questa infiammazione subclinica,
cosa fa poi nella realtà?
E come vedete, riduce la mortalità
per malattie cardiovascolari,
ma anche la mortalità totale
per tutte le cause.
Quindi, è una cosa interessante
che se uno segue
questo tipo di alimentazione
riduce qualche cosa che non vediamo,
ma riduce anche qualche cosa
che si può sperimentare
che è la mortalità per le malattie
più diffuse che abbiamo oggi,
che sono le malattie cardiovascolari.
Però, evidentemente,
non è soltanto la dieta mediterranea:
noi sappiamo tutti che è bene non fumare,
che è bene camminare,
fare attività fisica,
che è bene controllare il peso.
Se mettiamo insieme
tutte queste buone abitudini,
e poi andiamo a misurare,
nei dieci anni di osservazione
che stiamo seguendo, che stiamo facendo
su questa popolazione di molisani,
vediamo che i moli-sani
che non seguono questi stili di vita
hanno una curva di mortalità,
che è quella rossa in alto,
che è molto più alta, molto più pericolosa
di chi, invece, vivendo
nello stesso ambiente -
ovviamente calcolando tutte le variabili:
la variazione, qui,
sono solo gli stili di vita -
ha un rischio, una curva di mortalità
che è molto più bassa.
Quindi non c'è bisogno
di andare in ospedale,
non c'è bisogno di pensare alle farmacie,
non c'è bisogno di pensare ai farmaci.
Noi possiamo controllare la nostra salute,
e anche prevedere e prevenire
delle cose che temiamo
in maniera che è molto più vicina
all'essere sani che all'essere malati.
Allora, dopo aver visto queste cose
eravamo molto contenti
e molto soddisfatti.
Poi siamo andati a guardare
un pochino più da vicino,
e ci siamo resi conto
che la dieta mediterranea
non è uguale per tutti.
Non fa bene a tutti indistintamente.
Per esempio, chi ha studiato di più
ha più vantaggio dalla dieta mediterranea.
Voi direte: ma perché?
Non lo sappiamo ancora bene,
però sappiamo, perché l'abbiamo studiato,
che chi ha un grado
di istruzione superiore
legge meglio le etichette, è più critico,
e segue meno le notizie false
che i giornali e la televisione
ci propinano sulla salute ogni giorno.
Ogni giorno ci sono anche persone
che hanno dei canali televisivi
che dicono una serie di sciocchezze.
Ma quanto uno più è colto,
più ha sviluppato un sistema critico
per resistere a questo tipo
di malainformazione.
E l'altra cosa, ci siamo accorti
che non solo il medico,
ma l'Agenzia delle Entrate
gioca un ruolo importante
nella nostra salute.
La gran parte dei molisani
hanno risposto alla domanda
sul reddito familiare -
guardandoci bene se potevamo essere
degli agenti delle tasse
camuffati da un camice -
e quindi abbiamo potuto
studiare, e valutare,
che il reddito è più importante
del colesterolo.
Noi tutti vogliamo misurarci
il colesterolo;
ma il reddito familiare,
il reddito personale,
è estremamente importante.
Perché? Vi faccio un semplice esempio.
La dieta mediterranea
è caratterizzata da tante cose:
l'olio extravergine di oliva.
Allora, noi nei questionari chiedevamo:
lei consuma l'olio extravergine?
Sì sì: allora, un punto a favore.
E lei consuma l'olio
extra vergine di oliva?
Sì si: un punto a favore.
Poi, seconda domanda:
quanto costa mediamente,
una bottiglia di olio che lei compra?
14 euro.
Quanto costa una bottiglia, mediamente?
Quattro euro.
Allora è vero che tutte e due
seguono la dieta mediterranea,
è vero che tutte e due
condiscono l'insalata
con l'olio extravergine di oliva.
Ma capite che la differenza è enorme.
Quindi, anche all'interno
della dieta mediterranea
l'uguaglianza non è più una virtù.
E non basta più dire
che la dieta mediterranea fa bene:
bisogna definirne la qualità all'origine
e capire tutte queste cose
per poter avere un'idea di come va,
e come può andare,
la nostra salute
o il rischio di ammalarci.
E l'ultima cosa che abbiamo visto,
e che ci sta molto interessando -
siamo in una società che invecchia,
quindi stiamo diventando tutti più vecchi.
E quindi la vecchiaia, l'invecchiamento,
è certamente un problema
che ci interessa molto.
Allora abbiamo scoperto, nei molisani,
che non è tanto importante
l'età che deriva dai nostri passaporti
e dalla carta di identità
che ognuno di noi ha.
Ma l'età biologica, cioè l'età che deriva
da una serie di parametri -
che noi stiamo elaborando
per cercare di definire meglio.
Che cos'è questa età biologica?
L'età biologica corrisponde meglio
al rischio di ammalarsi
e alla possibilità di [man]tenere
bene la nostra salute.
Basta quindi con una medicina
che si accontenta
di misurare la pressione,
misurare il colesterolo,
la glicemia, l'esame delle urine.
Vogliamo una medicina che indaghi l'uomo,
che indaghi la persona
in tutte le sue caratteristiche.
Nelle sue passioni, nelle sue letture,
nei suoi viaggi, dove abita, come viaggia,
qual è la sua situazione socio-economica.
E così anche io, anche noi, come Diogene,
andiamo in giro, in mezzo alla gente,
a cercare l'uomo, a cercare la persona,
a cercare l'individuo.
In realtà, a me non interessa molto
che sia più sano o meno malato.
Mi interessa che sia più felice.
E mi interessa che abbia trovato un senso
alla propria vita e alla propria morte.
La ricerca continua.
Vi ringrazio.
(Applausi)